sì come mi vesto sempre un po da cani
nei video deciso oggi di fare un upgrade
del mio guardaroba di tirare fuori una
roba che avevo preso in giappone che
descrive la mia mascolinità
in tutte le sue sfumature grazie prego
ciao bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono valigeria ci siamo
tornati su non siamo tornati non l'ho
mai fatto
miss torino
[Musica]
ecco bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video io sono famiglia yohji siamo
su survive punto io sopravvivi punto io
butter royale hanno fatto non fu battle
royale che si chiama survive io sordi
vio allora doveva provare a vedere come
si fa vj prima della palazzina
faccio il dj a tempo perso non ci sarà
facile dire gioco da sorgere in compagno
di squadra e non ho assolutamente idea
di come si giochi pressoché 77 in vita
proprio un batter royal fichissimo va
bene vediamo se funziona allora tu puoi
tirare pugni
ci sono le mot ciao no space mente senza
aspettare ma e ci sono i secondi no si
stanno già uccidendo quindi si può ci si
può già uccidere va bene tu trovi il
armi è un batterio gli altri
litterio mode fighissimo portato
un'armatura a livello 1 è fatto è troppo
figo che ho assolutamente chiamare tornò
al suo gioco
sono queste le moto secondo rompere la
finestra per entrare dentro la casa ce
l'ha già addirittura l'air plain
fighissimo outfit di base è oggetto di
equipaggiato arcari salva 0 colpi va beh
usciamo resistendo per no no giudizio
c'è un tizio aiuto amici ho trovato un
fucile ma in scale tutto scarico questo
gioco che palle o solo i pugni vabbè io
scappo intanto m quello mi segue via via
via via via via 25 in vita paolo store
esistenza tantissimo
non so neanche dove la zona sicura non
ne ho idea mi chiama e bellissimo giorno
va però armi amaco è tutta gente morta
ma cavolo
c'è qualcuno che sia un'arma carica e
tutte le armi scariche avevano vabbè lo
scarico li mortacci vostri co
beck ha detto granada back ad un'altra
ucciso sa di no non ci sono ci sono
ucciso non ci sono se a caso sto male
che pro gamer l'ha ucciso sono
fortissimo sono ninja ma lui ci credo a
caso totalmente random no l'aveva sto
malissimo curati con onore i danni anche
lì che ho fatto sono fortissimo ma mica
ce l'ho fatta io ragazzo deve farcela
tutti ho trovato i colpi soda però come
si usano le come mi vendo bendati
fighissimo sto male va bene prima
partita random ho fatto i culi bene sono
contento per 8 1 x 2 cosa servono i per
due per otto un gioco in due t
vabbè a 6 in vita se uno si 6 ragazzo
nello show down finale
la prima partita sto male è fichissimo
va bene i nostri sei essenziale quindi
si vede anche molto più largo adesso non
sono io ma forse lui mp che mi fuori
dalle più largo no non lo so 5 invita
ragazzo down finale per me è già una
vittoria così ci sono riuscito a fare
una cosa incredibile tra in vita tra
invita la zona avanzata quanta secondi
chi arriva se si sparano sti due se si
spara il subentro alla fine sono un
fenomeno sono dietro l'albero sono nella
zona giusta porco demonio tra in vita
ecco no no dài dài dovevo vincere io
la prima partita random dai avevo già
avevo creduto tantissimo fatto due kill
può non ho mai giocato a sta roba nella
mia vita due kill l'ultimo show dal
finale nicchia fenomeno e non me ne
frega niente gioco è stato bellissimo e
sono stato il fenomeno sono contento
così se avessi vinto boh ciao però vabbè
è stato veramente figo va bene
riproviamoci allora lo so ma io non ho
capito
facciamo che ci riproviamo ha poi anche
osservare la gente mi sa che ho
osservato uno sbagliato come ha fatto ad
arrivare alla fine fortissima la gente
sa ancora come gioca come ho fatto è
arrivata da fitch a rifacciamo e meno
che meno la famiglia tenendo in cugini
come un altro menato vieni qua lorido
vieni vieni qua che schifo ayalon cc
music musi lui non saprà mai che sono
quindi eschilo trapano e che spara
eccolo
no dai siccome ho avuto culo tantissimo
arrivare al finale perché non so avevo
un sacco di armatura non lo so
rifacciamo vabbè la militari based fermi
tutti
la zona era per un attimo ciao ciao
fratte grazie del fucile a pompa gentile
allora dovrei ricariche dovrei curarmi
prima che le cure in stagione veramente
non so dove trovarle ecco magari era che
non c'è da te ma spara lui donna
sparatevi tra di voi sa ci sono le
capanne anche in mezzo all'acqua figo no
a fuoco se si mise ko che mira brutta
jazz ora cavalca sparatori tra di voi
non sparare a menti stanno sparando in
faccia non lo stai vedendo bravo
sollecitando un colpirmi neanche una
volta sono bravissimo di una [ __ ] che
pronuncia i colpi
gliel'ho fregata davanti però non ci
avevo propri colpi peccato cavolo svt
colpì subito avrei ucciso pure sarebbe
stata epica un'anziana a ci sono le band
ed entri cessi però non ci sono iniziati
i ragazzi sembrano munizioni subito
forse qua si no non sono quelle giuste
cavolo si possono far veramente paura
non so mai cosa c'è dall'altra parte
infatti mannaia ladra se riuscissi a
trovare dei colpi in sto gioco dei colpi
colpi se è successo qua colpi e colpire
i miei niente colpi sul frigo non mi
frega non si rompe tutto allagato
attenzione attenzione hanno trovato la
what cosa è normale questa cosa qui
nove fermi questo succede cos'è trovato
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no maledizione dai ma che cavolo
in chiaro quanto resisti
si vabbè ma che ma quanta vita ai spiega
quanto gli ho tolto danno provocato 108
danno subito cento ha vinto lui aveva
perché l'armatura porca vacca c'era un
mare di quanta roba qua quanta ce come
com'è possibile tutto sto troppo male ai
ragazzini di provare l'ultima così
giusto per vedere come va a finire
ciao zio ti ammazzo sappi che ti
ammazzerò non è vero nei mazzi su non è
vero ti ammazzo non so come va a finire
però proviamo l'ultima sono un po scarso
devo migliorare ma sono arrivato secondo
la mia prima partita varrà pure qualcosa
quindi va bene così raga siamo tutti
contenti
tutto a posto va tutto bene tutto bene
tutto benissimo tutto giusto stiamo bene
mi sputano addosso sono morto
va bene così mi guarda male qualcuno
sono morto talmente vocalità o ma ok non
ci credo ucciso c'è poi faccio più chi
da da quasi morto che da quando gioco
bene com'è possibile
ora se qualcuno gli fa il favore di non
ammazzarli mentre mi curo tipo lui
non ci credo
praga sono solo fortissimo sono più
forte da mezzo morto che che normalmente
cioè come possibile rimango così mango
con uno sputo di vita e sono più forte
siccome ancorati scopriamo tutta la vita
ho anche un bel per 4 ho visto messo
anche bernie che dada la partita buttata
che era sta diventando bo assurda storia
nessuno dovrebbe vedere se sono qua
dentro
cioè per vedermi devi entrare dentro qua
io posso vedere fuori
sì oggi sono il figlio non ci credo non
ci sono io non ci credo ragazzi fermi
tutti zitti 5 chili ma cosa mi sta
succedendo stava lì dall'altro perché
lui mi aveva sentito perché avevo
cambiato arma mi aveva sentito è tornato
indietro
io sono riuscito a ucciderlo come se non
me lo merito io sta partita guarda c'è
cavolo un francese pure tutto perfetto
questa partita che ansia di vivere che
ciò in questo momento 8 invita training
no no no io
noi dai loro non ci credo dai quanto gli
ho tolto potevo tolto danno subito 293
danno provocato 4 1 ma non solo lui e
non solo lui cioè danno provocati in
totale
ok ma perché sono capite che se
immortale quanto sta prendendo gli danno
ancora l'amore
guardalo guardalo ma cosa trovato
l'armatura livello 200 io gli ho sparato
il cecchino
vabbè praga e bellini sarà un miliardo
riso questa roba è fighissimo è troppo
figo
spero vi sia piaciuto a me un sacco cioè
ci giocherò da vita sta roba è
bellissimo perché altro perché le
partite sono veloci prefiggo quanto
ragazzi servizi lasciarlo quanto mi
piace anche vari socio è quindi d'ottone
descrizione se non siete persi discrete
e noi ci vediamo al prossimo video beh
ragazzi
[Musica]